hello everyone and welcome back to the
semi-finals of the knockouts of the
chesable masters it's pragananda versus
anish giri this is the the second match
that we are going to show we've seen one
game from the magnus ding uh match but
we're also gonna return to that one but
first we need to discuss this one as
it's uh well super important for the for
the tournament standings uh it's the
second game of their match first uh game
in in a draw and this one is uh well uh
really a crazy one so you guys will
enjoy it let's dive straight into it uh
prague has the white pieces and he opens
with d4 uh we have knight to f6 c for g6
knight to c3 and now we have d5 going
for the groomfield defense uh and it's
the standard line c characters knight
captures e4 knight captures and c3 b
captures and bishop to g7 and now bishop
to c4 this is all main stuff uh very
very sharp uh and um for those of you
who don't know prague is playing this in
two 2 a.m in the morning and as they
said on twitter he has school at 8 45 so
that's that's very impressive
uh so here's c5 again the main line
that's basically the idea behind the
the groomfield in the main line we want
to challenge this d4 square and we want
to try and get white to advance this
pawn to d5 of course white will never do
this uh oh of course sometimes white
will do this but it has to be a specific
line and of course
we are trying to
to undermine the position as much as
possible because white has this huge
center and we want to challenge it so
here knight to 82 we have castles by
anish and now uh castles by prague
knights to c6 again putting more
pressure on that d4 square and bishop to
e3 probably just defense and now uh
standard ideas here are bishop to g4 and
queen to c7 the these would be the main
moves uh what black plays here but anish
plays b6 so now he's ready to then get
to his light square bishop and this is a
quite quite a rare move uh prague says
all right this is rare but i know how to
play this and he strikes with h4
so now he wants to go h5 and then either
open up the h file maybe you're going to
play g3 king g2 put the rook on h1 then
try some sort of an attack or you will
even advance the pawn all the way to h6
the uh kinder blacks
blacks the dark square bishop so here we
have e6 threatening to pick up the pawn
h5 by prague and queen to h for now and
uh
uh the position has been reached in uh
quite a few games maybe you know 10 top
level games among van gaal had it
against mvl eventually had it against
the great dubo had it against svidler
and in all those games h captures on g6
was played however here prague prepared
uh queen to see one or maybe he didn't
prepare maybe he just played it over the
board as it's a very interesting move uh
what does it do and of course it is now
as of move 13 that we have a completely
new game well uh uh the bishop is now
guarded by the queen so a move like
bishop to g5 could almost trap
a trap on each queen let's say anisha
continues development bishop to b7 or
something bishop to g5 uh wha what can
you play it doesn't really matter what
what you capture uh your queen will will
get trapped for example queen captures
on h5 knight g3 and now after queen to
g4 bishop to e2 there's not not all that
much you can do here
uh so instead after queen to c1 anish
says all right it's a very interesting
move but it just blunders the pawn
doesn't it the four pawn is free for
grabs so first see characters on d4
attacking the bishop and the ones
progress recaptures just queen captures
on e4 and okay anish says i'm up upon
i'm you know living the good life what
do you have here so rook to d1 by prague
and not knight to a5 going after the
light square bishop and also trying to
get this bishop to b7 move in to put
pressure on g2 so first knight c3
attacking the queen and now uh queen
back all the way
to b7 you kind of want to play queen to
c6 and get the bishop to b7 but then uh
the the queen can easily be attacked so
here queen back all the way to b7 now
comes the bishop back to e2 here prague
wants to put the bishop on f3 bishop to
d7 ready to counter the bishop with
bishop to c6 and now pawn all the way to
h6
bishop to h8 and now bishop to f3
attacking the queen so you have to block
this otherwise you're going to lose
material bishop to c6 and now d5 so
every move uh they're a very very
forcing uh ideas by
bayang prague uh challenging the bishop
here and uh after e captures on d5 he
even plays bishop to d4 now he wants to
eliminate the dark square bishop and
then uh well the the black king will not
have uh not have a lot of squares there
will be a lot of dark square weaknesses
and probably will of course try to use
this to his advantage so here we have
rook 8 to d8 and now uh well anish is
just up two pawns he says where is your
compensation sure it's a it's a nice
position but is is it really
compensation uh progress plays bishop
captures on h8 king captures and did not
knight
on d5 grabbing the pawn uh but not
really because after bishop captures on
d5 there's queen to d2 incredible stuff
here now how are you
uh how are you playing this uh your
bishop is attacked for the moment you're
up a piece but if you try and save this
by playing bishop captures and if three
you just get checkmated as we cannot
forget the pawn is covering the g7
square after the queen is captured this
will be checkmate so after this queen to
d2 move we have queen to d7 by anish
queen to c7 might be a bit more precise
covering the covering the c3 square but
this is rapid chess so here we have
queen to c3 with check f6 blocking and
now rook captures on d5 and now uh how
do you how do you play this here rook
the c8 displayed uh progress queen is
attacked and it's a very tricky position
but it's one that if prabhu plays
correctly he has a completely winning
position so feel free to pause the video
and win this game for prague while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that you
can't just move your queen otherwise bad
things will happen and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is a
rook 8 e1 that's the good stuff here
problem is if you play something let's
say queen to d4 you want to play
something like rook to d7 and get a
winning position uh it's very easy for
black to activate the knight knight goes
here attacks the queen and once the
queen moves we just play knight e5 and
now we defend the d7 square attack the
bishop all of a sudden the knight you
know came from being uh
uh you know doing nothing on a5 to being
just a monster knight here on e5 so you
have to be very careful after rook the
e1 it seems like you're just offering a
queen trade but that's really uh you
know the last thing you're doing because
if if anish accepts this queen captures
and rook captures uh then how are you
stopping rogue d7 once this row comes to
d7 it's a game over there there's no
defending against this so anish can play
this after rook to e1 he moves the queen
back queen to c7 notice how we said that
the queen might be a little bit better
placed on c7 uh but now comes queen to
a3
again it's a rapid chess so i will show
how forcing queen captures and c7 is
because this is also winning uh rook
captures and now rook to d6
uh
uh just an incredibly powerful move
going after rook captures on f6 because
if the rook captures rook to e8 will be
checkmate we cannot forget again that
this pawn is preventing the king from
going to g7 and there's really no good
move here if we play if play f5 we just
play bishop here now we don't allow even
the king to come to g8 so the king is
completely boxed in and after you make a
move because you really don't have all
that many squares for your knight you
can play knight b7 to maybe try and
activate it we still play rook f6 and
that's it again if you capture you get
checkmated if you don't capture you can
play something like rook to d8 to go
after the bishop now we just play rook
fe6 and there's no defending this rook
to e7 will be game over if you go here
you go under the mask of the bishop and
well the only way to defend would be to
control the back rank but then you have
to give up the knight so this is just
terrible so that's one way to play it
probably decided to play it differently
he played queen to a3 but this allows uh
anish to activate his knight so knight
to c4
attacks the queen queen to e7 again he
offers a queen trade because if the
queens get traded off then the rooks are
just uh you know very very hungry pigs
on the seventh rank uh and here comes
knight to e5 rook the f7 was still
holding the game uh prague would still
be better but rook to f7 should still
hold however after knight to e5 uh well
with little time on the clock anisha
blunders the position completely and i
don't uh think you guys even need to
pause the video here to
figure out what what happens next but
just for fun uh feel free to pause the
video and find the actual winning move
for prague
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that we
are just actually trying to uh grab
control over the d7 square and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's rook uh rook e captures on e5 not
rook d captures an e5 that would be a
mistake because now we gain control over
the
d7 square now of course if you just
trade queens we are up a full bishop so
that's out of the question so the only
thing you can do here is f captures on
e5 this is what was played in the game
but now rook d7 we are threatening
checkmate so queen to c1 with check
and now again you don't want to play
king h2 because then queen captures an
h6 and you are in trouble this comes
with check so bishop to d1 and here it's
really uh hard to find the move queen
captures on h6 was played okay this
prevents checkmate but now queen
captures an e5 and he was in this
position on move 33 that anishigiri
resigned the game uh as there is nothing
more to be done here uh so really
wonderful game uh the problem is that
once uh king j8 is played uh our good
friend the bishop will have the will
have a final say now on the matter
bishop to b3 check and now you just have
to decide how many rooks you want to
give before getting checkmated let's say
rook c4 blocks bishop captures with
check king f7 uh we're gonna play bishop
captures on f7 with check and once king
f8 is played a queen to h8 or or you
know somewhere
will be checkmate so a really wonderful
wonderful game uh prague really did a
nice one here uh then the third game
ended in a draw and fourth game anish
won a brilliant brilliant game on demand
checkmate in prague with with the two
knights also a game that we are probably
going to cover but after the event is
over as anish is now out of the
competition prague is uh in the finals
uh and then in tie breaks um uh prague
one won the blitz section of the
competition uh anisha
it was a tricky position on each
blundered a piece and then he just uh
resigned and that was enough for for
prague to win the game so really a tough
tough match six games uh is what it took
for uh for prague to beat anish and get
into the finals and who he will meet in
the finals
well it will be the winner of the match
uh
dingler versus magnus carlsen for those
of you who still don't know who won i
will not spoil it in this one as you
will see because that will be my next
video that i'm publishing uh
well in uh maybe half an hour or maybe
an hour we'll see how it goes uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh congratulations to prague on you know
beating everyone up until this point
we'll see how he how he does in the
finals but regardless of the result the
games are incredibly interesting and
super enjoyable to watch uh so yeah uh
once again hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to salvatore cano uh and i would like to
thank robert kiefer mark manner
nagarjuna ponogoti and ballswing.com for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and i will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the finals uh uh until the end of the
tournament uh thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day